2011. oh oh hey there I was I was just
listing all of the times that my team
Southampton football club have won the
Premier League
now now I should qualify this by saying
that these dates are uh
sadly what is known as something called
synthetic
data
which is uh a nice way of saying fake
sadly Southampton have never won the
Premier League
synthetic data is information that is
artificially generated rather than
produced by events in the real world
which sounds a little well worthless so
perhaps it would surprise you to learn
that synthetic data serves some very
real productive purposes and is
increasing in popularity so let's
discuss first of all number one a
definition
of What synthetic data
actually is then we'll take a look at
some uses
and some benefits of synthetic data why
do you want all of this this fake data
around what can it do then we'll take a
look at number three
some challenges
of this whole approach and then number
four we'll take a look at actually how
to make some of this data which is the
generation component that is all what
we're going to talk about here with
synthetic data now synthetic data is
computer generated and it's derived from
existing data sets or from algorithms
and models to replicate the properties
and characteristics of real world data
and it's a broad term it covers a
variety of processes and techniques from
simple data synthesis all the way
through to deep learning models but why
do we need all of this fake daker well
well often the reason is that the real
data is either hard to come by or is
sensitive confidential information that
we can't readily get access to so now
I'm talking about things like
Finance so Financial
records those are going to be difficult
to get hold of and medical histories as
well things that might be confidential
so that really brings us into this idea
of talking about what advantages does
that bring well there are a number of
advantages so one of them is synthetic
data is cheap
easy to produce
and it also has the benefit of being
pretty good data specifically that this
data can be perfectly
labeled data so it is exactly defined as
we need it and real world data is after
neither of these things but what
possible use is it well that brings us
nicely to to section two uses and
benefits so a primary benefit lies in
the data hungry world of artificial
intelligence and machine learning a
model can be trained on plentiful
volumes of well labeled synthetic data
with the intention of ultimately
transferring the resulting machine
learning algorithms to real-world data
and according to Gartner by 2025 we will
need 70 percent
less real data to feed this hungry AI
pipeline now synthetic data will provide
domain specific well-labeled high volume
data at a reasonable cost and using
synthetic data things like fraud
detection algorithms can probe trained
models for security flaws and autonomous
vehicles can test drive scenarios on on
road layouts that don't actually exist
and synthetic data can be generated to
minimize bias that may exist in real
world data sets helping to make AI
models more fair accurate and
trustworthy so this all sounds great
synthetic data for all why even bother
with Messy real world data at all well
that brings us nicely to number three
challenges you see synthetic data can't
always accurately account for the
variety of real world factors but may
affect a model's performance it can't
replicate the kind of unanticipated
events that may occur in Real Life Look
if 10 years ago I generated synthetic
data for the next 10 winners of the
Premier League not many models would
have included Leicester city as winners
but Leicester city did win the Premier
League in 2015 despite starting that
season with five thousand to one odds
that they would win the title like they
say real life is often Stranger Than
Fiction
so how do you generate synthetic data
well the process is surprisingly
straightforward in a nutshell you'll
need to define the type of data you
require identify the data sources needed
and then generate the data according to
your specifications and the simplest
approach is to use some existing data
sets and then manipulate that to create
new examples so if we start here with an
existing data set we can perform some
sort of manipulation it might be that we
would add some noise into that data set
or we would transform some of that data
to create new data
there are also Advanced Techniques
things like generative adversarial
networks or Gans that we can use for
this which generate data by learning
from existing data and there are
synthetic data generators which use
mathematical and statistical methods to
generate data that follows specific
distributions
so synthetic data can be a powerful tool
allowing us to generate data that is
useful and an accurate approximation of
real-world data but we do have to be
aware of the potential pitfalls and
challenges associated with it
particularly when attempting to
replicate real world data and most
importantly don't trust any synthetic
data that emits Southampton from a list
of future Premier League winners
I mean
you never know
if you have any questions please drop us
a line below and if you want to see more
videos like this in the future please
like And subscribe thanks for watching